and of course this is a global crisis so
the number of coronavirus victims around
the world continues to soar this morning
Spain for example has more reported
cases than China and globally more than
34,000 patients have died and there are
now growing concerns about the virus
spreading in developing countries our
Charlie d'Agata shows how other parts of
the world are coping this is what it
looks like when a nation of 1.3 billion
goes into lockdown social distancing out
of the question in India as thousands of
now jobless workers made a mass exodus
back to their villages in South Africa's
poorest communities soldiers ordered
people home in no uncertain returns as
the coronavirus takes aim at some
developing parts of the world with
potentially devastating consequences but
in hard-hit Italy one sliver of optimism
although another 756 people died from
the virus the numbers there continue to
trend downward the dead have been
stacking up so quickly priests in the
north have had to conduct mass funerals
coffins carried by forklifts onto
military trucks for burial
death on an industrial scale they died
without the possibility to talk to their
loved ones without anyone who could
comfort Spain's death toll continued to
surge patients in overwhelmed hospitals
spill into hallways and in Hubei China
once the epicenter for the virus life is
returning to normal after the province
reported its sixth straight day with no
new cases now here in the UK the death
toll has now reached more than 1,200
many people asking how much longer can
this go on well this sobering assessment
from British health officials things may
not be back to normal for another six
months Gayle thank you very much Charlie
jagged a reporting from London